france soir oui je les dis est ce que tu
peux me garder mon kiosque pour l'après
midi parce que je vais avec casimir au
port et oui ok l'honneur eh bien il m'a
proposé de m'aider à réceptionner mes
tests de bonbons caisse de bonbons oui
je fais mes commandes pour les mois à
venir parce qu'il ya de plus en plus
d'enfants dans l'île alors comme ça
j'aurai des réserves at-il dit julie moi
j'ai de plus en plus de ballons à
gonfler mais dis moi tu seras peut-être
trop fatiguée si tu veux je ferme mon
casque comme ça tu ne t'en n'occupera
pas ne t'inquiète pas julie j'ai pris de
l'avancé sur mon travail et puis
aujourd'hui je prends que la journée
sera très calme je te remercie en tout
cas si tu as un problème tu sais vous
joindre judy je suis sûr qu'il n'y aura
aucun problème outil ce n'est que tout
seul j'ai un petit peu m'ennuyer mais
j'ai une idée chante pas chance aux
enfants à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure c'est une bonne idée ça chanter
ma chanson les enfants venez venez vite
rené vite je vais vous chanter ma
chanson
[Musique]
très
ce que je voudrais
l'un finir m
outre m
j'aimerais m
lady lay souris ont des vies
extraordinaires
je
n'explique ses mystères je voudrais être
très savants que d'être le secret des
choses y at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants roses qu'elle paie at-il
deviner ce qu'on trouve au delà des
étoiles il voit ton parfois des lions
des hommes s'ils gagnent les moineaux
les corbeaux et les marchés tout près
les canards
là
découvrant les dauphins l'est marceau
qui sont de vrais ma fille
[Musique]
son
c'est
comme des poissons dans la mer je
voudrais être très savants connaître le
secret des choses et il y at-il vraiment
quelque part des éléphants russe
quelqu'un est une deviner ce coup trouve
au delà des épaules ils voient trompa
repas des lions des hommes des cigales
créé
c'est ce que je voudrais
[Musique]
non
petit trait
[Musique]
m
vous avez constaté aujourd'hui que je
suis un peu seul dans l'île aux enfants
mais ça ne fait rien nous allons quand
même passer un bon moment ensemble
mais vous n'êtes à ça pardon mais pas ça
parce que je suis à 1 mais c'est vrai
vous êtes excusez moi je ne vous ai pas
vu arriver
mais qui de vous comment vous ne
reconnaissez pas le plus grand détective
de l'île aux enfants leur folle mais
alors qu'il laissait même en paix mais
enfin mais c'est moi vers le cloud mais
je vous assure monsieur que je suis né
en octobre n'était pas possible c'est
moi vous vous êtes françois je suis
franchement oui je suis françois mai
mais je suis aussi notre jeunesse on ne
peut pas être deux personnes à la fois
sauf dans les rêves et vous amène un peu
fatigué mon ami il n'est pas besoin
d'être détective pour s'en apercevoir
vous devriez vous reposer ou voire
peut-être un docte où j'en connais un
très bien le docte de babychou je vous
recommande bien je vous laisse les
enquêtes m'appelle me réclame je vous
salue le ballon
et si
oh ben ça alors je
je me vois maintenant
non mais
c'est pas vrai
j'ai vu mes allocs folle mais je les ai
vus
j'aurais
faut que je me secoue faut que je me
secoue ce
joli
nom c'est vrai chef
julie n'est pas là
l'enfant soir françois mon vieux
ressaisis toi
c'est certainement monsieur du snob qui
a voulu me faire une petite plaisanterie
c'est rien bon je vais quand même en
avoir le coeur net je l'appelais
allô monsieur juste 9 c'est france soir
bah ça pourrait aller mieux dites
monsieur du snob vous viendrez au jardin
cet après midi ah non vous vous êtes en
train de faire une petite belote avec le
facteur oui excusez moi de vous avoir
dérangé au revoir monsieur du sénat bon
voire
tuer vous eh bien eh bien le docteur
barbu je suis mon jeune ami que nous dit
on vous n'avez pas non kiki qui vous a
dit ça mon ami mr la forme ça faisait
beaucoup beaucoup de souci pour le muhr
vous l'avez vu mais bien sûr nous sommes
de vieux amis
oh non ça ça va pas bien du tout
n'aurait pas comme ça c'est plus votre
donnez moi votre
[Musique]
calme et
enduro pour
tous vous croyez en sus vous devriez
devriez aller à la montagne faire de
l'alpinisme c'est très bon pour le
poumon
voir m'appelle je voulais
vous surmener pas
[Rires]
or
je rêve je suis de plus en plus malade j
démission va
[Musique]
à l'eau
le commandant du port
bonjour mon commandant pourriez vous me
parler me passer julie d'urgence s'il
vous plaît je ne quitte pas
julie julie s'il te plait bien vite je
deviens fou
françois façon qu'est ce qui t'arrive
oui je crois bien julie j'ai vu le
docteur barbie chu et monsieur merlotte
folle mais ce qu'est ce que tu dis je te
dis que j'ai vu le docteur barbiche
monsieur merlotte folle jim enfin type
les autres voyous non non non non non je
les ai vus mais françois écoute c'est
toi qui a inventé ces personnages et qui
te déguiser pour faire une farce à
casimir je sais bien c'est bien il
n'empêche que je les ai vus
[Applaudissements]
mais je lui dis c'est ce que je me tue à
te dire
technico maintenant il manquait plus que
lui
mais parler mais
je suis bien content de te l'entendre
dire
oh là là
mon imagination le jus de deux bien
vilain tour
alors cette fois j'en suis sûr j'ai
complètement fou c'est donc il n'est pas
fou c'est julie je te dis que je suis
complètement fou d'ailleurs je sais ce
que je fais je vais suivre les conseils
du docteur barbiche aller quelques jours
me reposer à la montagne si tu es fou
moi aussi alors puisque j'ai vu pitt
nico et oui je lis tous les deux on est
complètement foulée c'est normal on
travaille trousses
alors là on travaille trop ni sur mu et
répète que nous faisons
je n'ai je te proposent ensemble de
partir quelques jours dans un petit coin
bien tranquille pour nous reposer bon
ben moi je vais faire ma valise et j'en
reviens d'accord et moi je fais la
mienne à tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
au rendez vous ici
[Rires]
font plus qu'un
voilà julie j'ai pris le strict
nécessaire oui bien moi aussi
j'étais chez monsieur du snob mais chez
casimir je l'aurais les à chacun un
petit mot pour expliquer notre départ
qu'un parti ou allez-vous elle nous
allons nous reposer tenir on ne veut pas
expliquer tout ça en détail mais sache
que julie et moi nous sommes très très
malade enfin mais vous ne pouvez pas
partir aujourd'hui pourquoi casimir nos
cieux gravelines bien justement
d'arriver
monsieur travelling j'aurais vu
débarquer au pan avec des grandes malles
pleines de déguisements il arrive dans
le jardin en passant par le petit bois
était disait je crois que je commence à
comprendre julie aps eh bien avec moi
cachons nous vite dans ton qui a fait
aimer expliquez moi
ce concert casimir c'est un grand
artiste à je vois que vous avez préparez
vos valises et vous avez enfin pouvoir
me suivent et accéder au sommet de la
gloire lorient ne vous retient ici
personne ne vous empêchera de vivre
votre vie
j'ai mis hors de nuire julie et françois
il se croit fou trois parties s'opposent
au lait ça monsieur travaille un vieux
vous êtes bien sûr nous
j'ai françois vous n'êtes pas parti non
j'aime pas partie monsieur pique nique
au monsieur merlotte folmer docteur
barbiche comment vous vous êtes déguisé
en enfin le même sort barbichon pique
nique on va enfin cesser c'est
incroyable et j'espère vraiment qu'il ne
la prendront pas enfin écoutés comme je
vous aime bien quand même je vous
promets que je ne leur dirai rien et toi
non plus françois s'est trop mis casimir
compte sur moi
[Musique]